aus berlin ist es jetzt zugeschaltet
rüdiger lucassen er ist der afg obmann
im verteidigungsausschuss
herr lucassen wie zufrieden sind sie
denn mit der arbeit von annegret kramp
karrenbauer gerät kramp karrenbauer hat
bisher sehr sehr viel angekündigt und
mit ihren ankündigungen belastet sie
auch die truppe ich muss erst mal unter
beweis stellen dass sie das auch
umsetzen kann
ich bin bisher noch nicht zufrieden
können sie da mal ein beispiel nennen
es ist ja auch im einspieler deutlich
gesagt worden dass die trendwende
die ihre vorgängerin eingeleitet hat
noch nicht gegriffen haben
gleichsam fängt frau kramp-karrenbauer
an die truppe du zürich zusätzliche
einsätze zu belasten sie will mehr
einsatz in mali sie hat angekündigt in
syrien einzutreten und sie hat nach der
libyen konferenz vom vorletzten sonntag
auch angekündigt in libyen aktiv zu
werden
so kommt die truppe und die bundeswehr
niemals zur ruhe und kann sich nicht
rekonstruieren
aber eigentlich ist es ja die aufgabe
der bundeswehr in einsätze zu gehen in
einsätze ja im einsätze im frieden und
hier um handelt es sich ja nicht den
artikel 87a unseres grundgesetzes sagt
der bund stellt streitkräfte zur
verteidigung auf und darauf aufbauend
wird auch das budget der
verteidigungshaushalt festgelegt aber
moderne außenpolitik ist ja auch immer
friedenspolitik und stück und dazu ist
ja vielleicht auch ein element die
bundeswehr kann man das nicht aus zu
sehen
sofern die sicherheitspolitischen
interessen der bundesrepublik
deutschland in irgend einer weise
berührt sind kann man auch sicherlich
darüber nachdenken
im rahmen der außenpolitik die
streitkräfte einzusetzen
aber wir können nicht überall in der
welt sein und schon gar nicht mit
unseren streitkräften die aufgrund der
politischen führung oder der
merkel-regierung sich in einem so
desolaten zustand befinden
da ist es ja schon fast obsolet so frage
wo liegen die größten probleme wenn sie
von einem desolaten zustand reden was
war wie sehen sie den wehrbericht was
ist da das größte problem derzeit nun es
gibt für alles eine lösung frau bald es
und es ist ja auch vom wehrbeauftragten
immer wieder betont dass er eine
mängelliste erstellt er ist nicht für
die lösung zuständig die lösung liegt
darin der truppe im grundbetrieb das
heißt zu hause erstmal die ruhe zu geben
das material auf vordermann zu bringen
vernünftige beschaffung einzuleiten und
für die motivation der soldaten nämlich
für den typischen soldatenberuf zu
sorgen herr lucas und sie waren ja
selbst jahrelang jahrzehntelang soll da
das geht jetzt um rechtsextreme
tendenzen auch in der bundeswehr haben
sie das in ihrer zeit auch erlebt nein
das habe ich nicht erlebt und ich bin
auch nicht sicher ob sich hier so viel
verändert hat eins vorweg geschickt so
daten die gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung agitieren
gehören aus dem dienst der streitkräfte
entfernt egal aus welcher
extremistischen richtung sie kommen aber
wir spielen 550 soldaten stehen unter
verdacht dass das da kann man das ja
nicht wegleugnen das ist da eine gewisse
tendenz gibt wie auch immer man die
bewertet richtig verdachtsfälle 550 das
sind bezogen auf die streitkräfte 0,3
prozent und wenn festgestellt wird dass
in 19 uhr in 2009 10 davon acht
rechtsextremisten waren dann waren es
bezogen auf die streitkräfte weniger als
0,05 prozent ich denke das ist wichtig
diese zahlen in ein richtiges licht zu
rücken
aus meiner sicht hat die bundeswehr kein
problem mit
es muss kritiker sagen man hat aber zu
lange weggeschaut
sie sagen jetzt es gibt kein problem
könnte die wahrheit nicht doch irgendwo
in der mitte liegen
die wahrheit liegt dort wo sie nüchtern
analysiert wird und es ist aufgabe des
präsidenten des militärischen
abschirmdienstes programm hier auch
fakten vorzulegen wenn er aber dann sagt
dass die verdachtsfälle sich im
phänomenbereich rechts bewegen dann sind
das nicht fakten und wird dem leiter und
juristen wie er es ist eine solche
behörde nicht gerecht er hat nicht den
politischen kampf mit anderen mitteln zu
führen sondern er hat fakten vorzulegen
und er hat auch zu benennen was
verdachtsfälle sind und wir haben ja
genügend beispiele wo zweifel angebracht
sind ob hier schon gegen die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
verstoßen wird der emma de meldet
besonders viele fälle
man muss es ja konstatieren dass er sie
meldet in der ksk kommando spezialkräfte
wie erklären sie sich das das ksk ist
eine besondere einsatz form und einem
besonderen szenario ausgesetzt wenn
immer zum beispiel deutsche
rucksacktouristen zu tief hinein torecke
gebiet eindringen dann ist es das ksk
was woche lang sich nicht nur
vorbereiten muss sondern auch im
einsatzland für die befreiung oder
rückführung von geiseln sorgen so diese
diese mission die geheim vonstatten
gehen die führen auch zu einem einem
gewissen chorgeist und innerhalb eines
core geistes entwickelt sich auch eine
sprache und die mag außenstehenden
vielleicht ungewöhnlich erscheinen aber
die außenstehenden sind auch nicht in
einem solch gefährlichen einsatz
und da entwickeln sich durchaus sprüche
die wir so nicht kennen aber deswegen an
der verfassungstreue unserer soldaten
und vor allen dingen der auch des ksk es
zu zweifeln er das ist nicht mal 1 nein
das ist nicht so der obmann im
verteidigungsausschuss ganz herzlichen
dank nach berlin
dein kind rowohlt ist